you're here in Germany meeting foreign
office officials last month you met the
--use brexit negotiator Michele Barney
oh what is it that you would like to see
from Europe and European negotiators in
order to protect Scottish interests
during this brexit process I think at
the moment the movement has to come from
the UK site because the hold up in the
negotiations as far as I can tell is
because there is a lack of clarity from
the UK and a lack of realism from the UK
import it's trying to achieve if we can
get over that and if the negotiation
becomes about something that is sensible
and achievable then I think we will see
things into a different phase that's why
I continue to argue for options like
customs union and single market because
they're not as good as membership of the
EU but they do address a lot of the
issues that are still waiting to be
resolved from the European side as far
as Scotland is concerned I have always
recognized that the negotiation is with
the UK government but I've asked for and
by and large received a lot of
understanding from Europe of Scotland's
position and I think our willingness to
help as much as possible but getting the
UK and a good sensible realistic
negotiating position is in everybody's
interests so Scotland as I'm sure you're
aware voted 62 percent against leaving
the European Union yourself have been
quite critical of the brexit process so
far in fact Tory's amazed conservative
parties is even said that you've been or
your party has been weaponizing for exes
as a means for pushing the independence
cause what what would you say to that
and is there sort of are you working
towards a timeline for a second
independent vote well firstly as for the
accusations of weaponizing breaks or
under main in the UK negotiation it's
it's nonsense the only reason that I can
say the things that I say if it breaks
it and mean them sincerely and have so
much frustration is because the UK
government is making such a mess of the
negotiation and it doesn't have a
negotiating strategy worthy of the name
and it's the sooner that is resolved the
better in terms of Scotland's future I
support Scotland being an independent
country I don't think that's going to
come as news to anybody
I think Scotland will become an
independent country that's the best way
to secure our relationships within the
British Isles but also secured our
relationships across Europe the European
single market is eight times the size of
the UK trading market so it's important
that Scotland has both and also that we
remain an open outward looking country
but the timing of a decision on Scottish
independence I've also said it really
has to wait until we get greater clarity
around the break set process and what
the relationship between the UK and the
EU is going to be so we'll wait and
until we hopefully get some of that
clarity before making any decisions
about the timeline you said that you're
hopeful that that clarity might come by
the end of the year is that's still the
case what that's what the Prime Minister
will see and you know that's what Michel
Barnier will see that by the end of this
year by October there will be an outline
of the future relationship hopefully by
that time there was drol agreement will
have been settled and a transition
period will have been guaranteed and
what we are told by both sides of the
negotiation is that there will be
significant detail about the terms of
the future relationship will albeit
there will still be many issues to be
finally negotiated and implemented no I
I don't have any difficulty seen I have
skepticism about whether that can be
achieved in that timescale but you know
I I have to at this stage take it face
value what the negotiators are seeing
but polls have shown no change in
attitude when it comes to a second
independence referendum in 2014 in fact
55 percent of people voted against it
given that the fact that there doesn't
seem to be a renewed appetite for
independence at the moment shouldn't
Scotland be focusing more on making a
success of brexit rather than pushing
for a second independence vote well
that's exactly what we're doing trying
as how does it we can to get the best
outcome from breaks or the least bad who
come from breaks it and focusing on that
before taking decisions about the timing
you know polls can be read by
politicians and all sorts of different
ways myself included but you're all of
the polls almost all of the poll since
2014
showing support for independence at
least as high or in many cases higher
than it was in the referendum in 2014
and of course in the course of that
campaign in 2014 the polls moved
significantly support for independence
at the outset of that campaign was not
much over 30 percent by polling day it
reached 45 percent so you know when
arguments are made and the case is
engaged then opinion can change I
suspect that we are seeing opinions
change rapidly in Scotland not just
because of what's happening with BRICS
overall but because of some of what I've
described as the subplots - breaks it
which is the impact on the powers of the
Scottish Parliament which I think is
making a lot of people in Scotland very
angry and frustrated recent weeks have
seen your MPs walking out of Westminster
in London your MPs have also decided not
to approve the EU with drawable how
would you describe relations between
Edinburgh and London in the moment
relations are strained and that perhaps
was to be expected given that Scotland
is being dragged down a road and out of
the EU when as you said earlier oh and
we didn't vote for that 62% voted
against that so perhaps relations were
always likely to come under strain
because of that it's been compounded by
the fact that the UK government has
taken a very high-handed attitude to
Scotland's and tris and has sought or
gone about the breaks of process in a
way that raids roughshod over the powers
of the Scottish Parliament and that has
compounded matters and we've seen since
MPs walked out of the House of Commons
as a way of making their frustration
felt we've seen membership of the
Scottish National Party my own party go
up significantly so there's clearly a
real frustration in Scotland not just at
breaks that we want to continue to be an
open outward-looking
European country but also the way in
which the brexit process is undermining
the very foundations of our own
Parliament in Scotland